Beyonce just texted
really
shut up just checking and it felt like
the whole world tuned in to watch Prince
Harry and Meghan markle's bombshell
interview with Oprah Winfrey last year
and turns out Beyonce did too so is
Harry and Megan had seen the potential
um to to win public sympathy they they
do clearly feel that they have been
victims of the Royal Family's Behavior
they've clearly felt misrepresented
unsupported on Thursday the second part
of the couple's docu-series Harry and
Megan dropped and shows the aftermath of
that tell-all sit down including the
moment queen bee reached out to Meg
Beyonce just texted
really much
shut up just checking and
he's checking in just casual I'm still
guess
she knows who I am during the explosive
interview Harry and Megan got candid
about the events that led to their
decision to step down as senior working
members of the British royal family
making bombshell allegations like
concerns in the family about what color
their son's skin would be when he was
born the suggestion that
senior member of the royal family
um was concerned about how dark the
couple's child might be it's shocking
the suggestion is very clear the
suggestion is that there is racism
within the institution I mean that is a
huge and explosive allegation to make
queen bee watched all that go down and
simply reached out to let Meg know she's
loved she said
just wants me to feel safe and protected
she admires and respects my bravery and
vulnerability and she thinks I was
selected to break generational curses
that need to be healed
that's well sad and while Harry's
obviously getting a kick out of that new
celebrity status Beyonce just texted
he does Miss a few things about Royal
life I missed the weird family
gatherings when we're all sort of
brought together Under One Roof for you
know certain times of the year
um
that I miss of course Harry and Megan
now live in Montecito California with
their two children Archie and lilibet
but it is of course a beautiful home
it's a forever home and somewhere where
they'll lay their route they're really
able to now create a safe space away
from prying eyes yeah being part of the
institution meant that I was in the UK
so I missed the UK I miss my friends
um and I've lost I've lost a few friends
in this process as well but the tension
between his brother Prince William dad
King Charles and Grandma Queen Elizabeth
II that part he's okay leaving behind it
was terrifying to have my brother Scream
and Shout at me and my father say things
that just simply weren't true and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of take it all in William
simply cannot forgive Harry not just for
leaving but for how he left
[Music]
foreign